by the end of this month
by law the pentagon is required to tell
the public
what it knows about ufos we're hearing
the report is coming out on or about
june 25th yesterday someone at the
pentagon gave an early read on the
report to the new york times
in that story we learned the pentagon
cannot say that ufos are from
a different solar system but they can't
say they're not they can't say they're
from
china or russia but they can't say
they're not doesn't sound like they can
say much
of anything luella zondo is a long-time
pentagon official for years he oversaw
investigations at the u.s government
into ufos
he's left now he and his organization
skyford have obtained a government
document
that proves the advanced tic tac ufo has
been tracked by american military intel
services
for at least 70 years that's much
earlier than we thought
lou elizondo joins us tonight lou thanks
so much for coming on
tucker always a privilege thank you
thank you i want to ask about this
document
of first before i ask you about the the
upcoming report what is
what is this document you've obtained
show us well this is a document that was
obtained through the freedom of
information act
and it demonstrates quite clearly that
we have had
issues with these if you will these uaps
or ufos
in the vernacular for for at least 70
years at least since 1950 probably
earlier
and this is official u.s government
correspondence this isn't some
eyewitness report from from a civilian
this is official government
documentation from military personnel
to very senior military brass and what
it says is
very quite compelling that look we've
had a lot of military and intelligence
eyewitnesses to include
special agents and scientists and all of
them are seeing these things and more
importantly
the frequency uh has occurred on a
regular and
continuing basis over sensitive uh u.s
military facilities
and this has been occurring tucker again
since 1950 uh according to
official us government documentation so
so think about that for a minute
when we talk about that on the backdrop
of this this recent revelation that
the u.s government has finally admitted
that this is not some sort of secret u.s
technology
well okay that's great we already knew
that but now there is some wiggle room
to say well maybe it's some sort of
foreign adversarial technology well
here's the problem with that theory
because we know that the russians after
the
after the berlin wall came down they
shared a lot of information with us
there was this
five-year period or so this this new
romance between us and russia
where they shared a lot of their ufo
information with us and by the way they
were seeing exactly the same thing in
their skies
that we were so so we're sure it's it's
not russian so then really the only
other
other country that could possibly be
would maybe be china well
let's look at that for a second tucker
because you're talking about a country
that
for somehow for 70 years has kept this
technology that was at least a thousand
years ahead of us
kept it secret was able to employ it
against us
all the way back in 195 1950. by the way
this is the same country that steals
billions of dollars worth of our
technology each year
trying to keep a competitive advantage
to this day with our country
now does does that make a whole lot of
sense to you
no no it does i mean there were famines
in china 70 years
ago quickly there seems to be some
connection
anecdotally there is between these
objects and nuclear reactors nuclear
warheads nuclear powered vehicles
submarines and warships we didn't get
nuclear technology of course until the
end of the second world war
44 45 we had airplanes
we had an army air corps going back to
the first world war were there sightings
of these before the united states
possessed nuclear technology
there were anecdotal sightings but
really there seems to be a significant
uptick once the united states and other
countries really entered into
into the atomic age we began to see an
increased
uptick what appeared to be some sort of
reconnaissance or surveillance of our
nuclear technology
our nuclear development uh whether it's
power or propulsion or weapon systems
and related technology that's just a
it's amazing it's a tantalizing
suggestion i'm not sure what it means
but i think it's interesting as hell
lou elizondo i appreciate your coming on
tonight i hope we see you soon
always a pleasure thank you tucker so
crime rates
are going up around the country you
already know that we have new evidence
tonight though that the murder rate in
america's biggest cities are actually
higher than anyone has previously
reported we have those numbers
next